all right
good evening
and welcome to uh the
pmp certification examination tips and
tricks
uh essentially needed for anyone to
pass the pmp examination with full
confidence and
able to get pmp certification
so i'm
chandra mr cmr certified
itil
v3 expert
one moment
so am i am i audible
you people can just confirm me am
audible
all right
thank you so
here we will be looking at understanding
about pmp certification why one should
go for pmp certification
the importance of bmp certification and
who should go for pmp certification for
example i am practicing project manager
and
i do not have any credentials to
demonstrate or showcase myself
so certifications gives that recognition
so that the person who is practicing
project management having pmb
certification will have a recognition as
a project manager
and have a better edge for in terms of
promotion or in terms of
getting new job role or project
management etc
so similarly someone
who does not have a project management
certificate like pmp and practicing the
uh
profession in project management
uh they would even though they have good
capability they may not get the good
platform to
perform
simply because pmp is a globally
recognized certification and that will
take you to the platform required
right
so now uh what is pmp certification is
all about
now pmp certification is a product of
pmi project management institute
and the certificate would come from
pmi the pmp certification would come
from pmi
and it is
the training one has to go through a
training
organization like simply learn who is
authorized training partners of bmi and
after going through the training they
should register themselves for the
examination in
pmis visiting pmi's website
so
simple any training institute like
simply would not conduct the examination
only pmi along with pearson vue would
conduct the examination and one should
go and register with pmi and produce the
proof for this training as well as some
experience in project management to take
up the pmp certification examination
so let us look at few details about
why should one take pmp certification
right
so having pmp certification one would
recognize themselves or have a better
recognition as a project manager one is
that other one is uh the individual
would understand
what is the best practice in project
management
if there are there are certain scenarios
where they are not doing it right
they may able to have this particular
project management framework understood
well
and put that into practice better right
so one would make
a project managers practice better
and what is what are those do's in
project management and what are those
are not that clarity one would get so
that way one can able to do what is
required to
do a best project management and also
have a good recognition across the globe
and in the resume perspective in the
recognition perspective it would add
value in a great way so add value to the
resume
[Music]
that will take you to a better platform
the one has a certificate do not have a
certificate but has a good capability of
project management may not have a
recognition because rizzo speaks
everything the moment there is a
project management certification bmp is
mentioned in the resume obviously that
will get a better edge why because it is
understood that someone who has gone
through the framework and cleared the
examination
they would have a good understanding
about the project management framework
and they have practiced to certain
extent so
very important thing is
whenever there is a
certification like project management
once the person has a clarity about
project management framework
and has practiced a certain time because
pmp certification the prerequisite of
pmp certification
is to have some
specific amount of experience before
they get into project management
practice or before they get into pmp
examination someone who is fresher never
never was in the project management
journey and never did any role in the
project management they may not be
eligible for taking up the pmp
examination there is some specific
experience requirement in the project
management area for someone to become
eligible one of the prerequisite to
become eligible for
pmp examination so
that way a practicing personnel who is
into project management for some time
can have a better edge to move forward
that is another
evaluation thing what happens
then more job opportunities obviously
because of the
recognition what the individuals would
have because of this best practice
certification which is recognized across
the globe
and salary hikes obviously there is a
survey which simply learn itself has
done at least we have seen 25 to 30
percent of the hike compared to the
person who has a project management
certificate vf
what says someone does not have the
certificate
globally this survey was done and we
found that
so then validates dedication to the job
now in any profession
learning is something which has to
happen throughout the journey of the
profession so someone who stops learning
is equal to stopping their journey in
their profession itself so continuous
continual learning and upgradation is
what what is required which is very
essential for someone to have the
recognitions and growth in their career
so someone accomplishing the pmp
certification itself is a indication as
this individual
dedicates himself or herself
to learn and then
accomplish new skills and capabilities
and add value to the system so that is
the dedication what
one would have
recognized it validates the dedication
to the job is validated
through the certification
so someone who does not have uh the
certification someone who does not
showcase such things
so
[Music]
right so once once the
certification is that for example today
i have pmp certificate tomorrow i'll go
to something like program management or
something like uh architecture kind of
thing
like with many different certification i
get into slowly as i get into different
certification stream
i am learning something i'm broadening
my perspective so when we when it comes
to learning it's obviously a curve
should go like linear but many times
the skills which is around the specific
core skill is very important for example
if i am a domain expert in some
technology technology area for example i
am a telecom engineer for example so
how long i can just do an engineering
job so there are a lot of projects which
comes up in that area itself so project
management is one area so management
streams are bigger things so project
management is one among that
so i've learned project management
certification and i have a core
expertise of telecom engineering so that
adds value
again
as i go through a technology perspective
learn something so the moment you become
a certified project management
that any management learning like
project management pmp actually stresses
on continued learning and improvement
so it may be in terms of scope maybe in
terms of
cost management maybe in terms of
purchase
quality management risk management
stakeholder management communication
management so you as a certified
professional start recognizing the need
for them and why should we focus on that
so that way it will enable you to work
on more
learning and progressing
so and one more important thing is pmp
certificate is valid for three years so
every three years
one should be renewing it by producing
the proof of education what they have
learned plus giving back to the
community of project management so that
we will see as we get into the handbook
of pmi so that you will have some better
understanding of that
so then it is globally acknowledged as i
mentioned earlier pmp certification is
recognized across the globe
and there is a better project
performance because
i have learned what is that best
practice of project management is
so i will have a better performance i
demonstrated properly compared to the
one which i was doing the way i
understood without knowing the best
practice since i know the best practice
now i would do it better
then increase networking opportunities
because pmi also
recommends and provides opportunities to
come together to collaborate right so a
lot of community forums are there where
it's like simple and also as a community
forum where one can participate and then
increase their knowledge about the
subject
then job security because the
certificate is well recognized obviously
you will have a better edge to move
forward
and you will be mastering in practical
application of the
project management practice as a
project management practice in specific
so next is uh tips on certification
examination
so let us look at understanding pmp
examination so
pmi website will help you find enough
information to begin with pmp
certification examination anyway uh i
will run you through that what details
you might require to go through there
so the website for you to look at is
pmi.org
and the pmbok project management body of
knowledge is a main reference one of the
reference
so till the sixth edition of
pmbok
till december 2020
the entire framework education used to
be only on pmbok
so now the latest examination content is
not just on pmbok guide alone bimbo
guide is one of the main reference books
whereas many other books are referred to
create examination content outline for
pp examination so what it what is that
content of examination content outline
we'll go through that as well so but you
may require to have a clear clarity
about
pmbok and the content in bimbo so before
we get into pmbok you should go through
the material of learning first
then you can touch on pimba
it is also important to know that what
is the pattern of examination what all
the topics may appear in the examination
so we will understand this as we go
through examination content outline as
we visit the pmp
pmis website so we have a handbook
exclusively for examination content
outline
what are the domain areas to be looked
at and in each of the domain areas what
are the topics covered and what are the
enablers tasks which needs to be focused
upon so when that is explained in the
examination content outline
make it a handbook
right that's about the content what we
need to look at with the domain and how
one should have a study plan there
should be roadmap now whenever we study
to a competitive examination
whichever we took in academics for
example we did not had any questions
which are like multiple choice mini
there were few though
but we may require to articulate the
things based on the questions and
depending on that awareness about the
topic we need to explain but here it is
not that
you have a
big list of questions you are required
to sit for 230 minutes 180 questions and
focusing on 180 questions continuously
is not easy thing so this requires a
specific type of practice for enabling
yourself to
do it better in the examination
so you might require to plan it well
study plan should be well so now when i
say date of the examination generally uh
based on the learning curve of the
people someone would take within a month
they can
practice it and pass the examination i
did that
when i had a certification
but i don't say everything one it is
possible to do it because i have a some
amount of time to focus on this
examination that's why i could able to
schedule
for one month i cannot schedule exam
tomorrow and go i should work backwards
as i submit the exam application
uh once i have approval from pmi a one
year approve approval one-year validity
it will have one year violation if an
approval today
so from today onwards one year i will
have the approval to take up the
examination
so any date i can schedule i will have
for example it now it is august i would
say you may be
october sometime i will schedule and
i'll work
backwards my plan will be working
backwards and accordingly i'll prepare
myself
so many people what they do the mistake
is they will wait till the last moment
and then start preparing it doesn't work
so exam date please look at your
learning curve you know better than
anyone else about yourself
it may be two months it may be three
months i'll fix it a specific date and
work backwards and start preparing and
committed commitment is very important
right once you have the exam date fixed
the time what you need to
dedicate are you dedicating one hour
every day or two hours every day
or
half an hour every day and weekend i'll
spend four hours for us any the such
things which is feasible to you can do
but only thing it should be committed a
committed effort because it is not just
about certificate you may require to
practice the project management as you
get into the real world into your
organization as you get into the actual
project management profession
there you need to demonstrate this you
cannot just have a certificate one side
and ignore that and start something else
on ground it will not work so it may be
you may balance balancing both and one
more thing what we should remember is
uh
best practice certificates tell
something some best practices it says
that also requires certain customization
to fit into the environment where we are
doing the particular practice
so how many hours one can do devote on
daily basis you decide but you have to
spend time each day because it is a
profession which you will be doing day
in day out on ground and this is reality
we will get into so that is the reason
you should be like as you learn swimming
or riding a bike or bicycle you will
never forget
same way this was you should get
programmed
it is a practice right it's not just i i
learn this i get the certificate i
forget about it it cannot be like that
so that is the reason regular practice
is very important
and resources what are the resources are
required
to learn
now if you
think about once you go through the
training we simply learn
simply learn has learning management
system where some amount of course
details are there
you can go through the videos training
recordings will be provided then you
will have a simulation environment
the way the actual exam looks like that
simulation environment would be there in
simultaneous lms
uh in parallel to that there will be a
learning management system uh learning
operations portal which is
provided by pmi itself
where you will have the student handbook
material
which you will go and learn that and
entire training would be based on that
material which is provided by pmi and
there in that portal also you'll have
certain set of videos materials to
download
and then you'll have that
pre-assessment before you take the
training post assessment after the
training
so this will help you now once you go
through all of this you may able to go
through pmbok and other books what is
referred by
pmi but in my opinion before you get
into pmbok and
rest of the books what is referred by
pmi first go through a learning
operation material provided by pmi
become comfortable with it in parallel
you go through the material of simpler
whichever is published in simplest
learning management system
and the simulation platform what simple
one has that will help you a lot
at least you may require to focus on
scoring 90 95 percent in that particular
simulation so only then you have that
level of confidence to go to real exam
so you can use those sources and
training
training is very important or that is
one of the prerequisite before you go
for pmp examination
so 35 pdus professional development unit
the training provided by a registered
education provider
or authorized training partner of pmi
would probably
so that is very one of the prerequisite
for
taking up the examination if you do not
have that certificate
from authorized training partner of pmi
you cannot attend the examination so
that is one of the prerequisite we will
see the eligibility take up the pmp
examination
so
for now i have an understanding i have
the clarity that one of the prerequisite
to take up the pmp examination
is that training certificate what you
get from the training institute so that
certificate should be from the
authorized training partner only right
so and that training will be based on
the examination content outline what pmi
has shared and
pmi would regularly audit this check
what kind of training is being done by
the training institutes are they going
as per the
guidelines given by pmi that pmi
regularly checks that is the reason you
should go through authorized training
partners of pmi
right exam
subjects so
it is based on that examination content
outline what is
defined by pmi so
they
divide that into domain areas as i
mentioned earlier what are those domain
areas we will see will explain what it
is at higher level so that you will have
the clarity
and you should put everything into those
domains entire project management
practice into
those domains and then see through that
how exactly we are doing in real time
and put that into practice as well as
learning for examination so whenever i
say i'm learning for examination
many player times we may require to
unlearn as well why should i learn
for example
one of the customers like customer
engagement you need to do during project
management so customer is not agreeing
for the deliverables what you have made
so best practice would say
[Music]
link it to the requirement what is
signed off demonstrate things
accordingly to the customer and close if
best practice says that
how do you demonstrate that
that requires a kind of relationship
stakeholder management will come into
picture
so you should
build yourself to handle that way
right
so
best practice would not say how what is
the best way to do that and convince
customer because each individuals are
different that depends on your
interpersonal skills so beyond the best
practice there is something what you do
in real time to take things forward but
don't bring that dynamics into the
examination
just read the question as it is
limit your thought process to the
question and only that question
don't read something above or below
around that particular questions and
find the meaning out of it
exactly the wordings what is used in the
question and understand exactly and
relate that to the answers
only then you can able to select the
right answers
and that's about examination so third
tip
enroll in exam reports and solve a lot
of practice questions
so as i was mentioning you
uh simply learns learning management
system as a
simulation platform where you get an
opportunity to solve
a lot of questions typical questions
which will come in the examination
so you should enroll for preparation
spend some time and we have the
community forum in simple learn where
you can post the questions if you are
having some
difficulty in understanding the right
answer what is given and why this is
right answer
so you need an explanation whatever the
explanation is given in lms you may find
difficult to understand that it may not
be okay
so you may require to
have a query so you can put the query in
the community forum one of the best
practitioner i mean
subject matter expert who is practicing
this can give you the clarity as an
answer so many people compliment and
contribute there
right so you will not have any
difficulty so simple learn team would
help you in many ways
so it is very important to solve
question paper to have an idea of the
examination and to undergo the dynamics
so remember i told the examination is
for 180 minutes
2 30 so 230 minutes 180 questions
230 minutes 180 questions so just
imagine you focusing on a screen
[Music]
for 180
question on 180 questions for 230
minutes 2 30 minutes is 10 minutes
lesser than four hours how easy or
difficult is that so many people are
told in office visit for eight hours
nine hours in front of the system but
are you concentrating on a question to
answer
you will not be doing that right so
you'll be writing an email or you may be
having some discussions over the system
or you may be coding something or you
may be creating some proposals
like with many other things you do as
you work in real time a lot of dynamics
are involved you're not continuously
focusing on something
here continuously you have to focus and
answer
230 minutes
means one minute something some second
should be the one what you have for each
questions
not given two minutes so that's the kind
of uh
timeline you have to answer all the 180
questions so for that you need to
practice now practicing on the subject
is one part understanding the subject
matter and then seeing the domains and
framework is fine
even though i know the answer i may fail
in selecting the right answer simply
because i am tired
i am tired looking at the screen my body
is paining i am unable to sit properly
likewise many things will come and
bother you
right so it's a wavering mind right so
too many things will be running in mind
so you may require to take a full
fledged examination before you go for
the actual examination at least two to
three times since it is lms will have
full fledge to 30 minutes
simulations you can sit
set your body mind and ability to
concentrate other questions
many times people will know the answer
but they end up in selecting the wrong
answer just because the concentration
level is less
they understood the question
differently what question meant was
different and what you understood was
will be different and you end up in
answering something wrong
that should not happen so for that you
need to prepare your body as well
and mind as well as your ability to
concentrate
so next is about
join pmi community
and connect with the project managers so
pmi
has a community
in the pmis website where you can become
the member
and becoming member is one thing which
pmi recommends for the first time when
you go for examination lot of discount
you will get in the examination
so membership fees plus examination fee
both combined together
you will have a
lesser
value compared to i am going to
examination without having membership
so that way pmi is promoting that by
offering the lower price
so now membership is valid for one year
so if you if you want to continue
membership you keep renewing that
membership every year you pay the fee to
pmi and do it
certificate is valid for three years pmp
certificate so you might require to
renew it that is a different cycle
altogether
now in addition to this we have a
community forum in simply learn which i
mentioned where you will also have a
connect with the mini subject matter
expert many other practitioners
so you will know sonic unable to clarify
your doubts
not just about pmp certification
examination even after getting certified
you can be active there put across your
experience in real time
ask the questions from people who are
actually subject matter experts as well
as who is practicing and
it happened so that i think this was a
few years back where one of the person
was finding difficult to have a solution
in this project even though the details
are very confidential for him to share
he told this as a story
so this is the kind of scenario a
project manager is how do we resolve a
lot of discussion went through so he
could able to find the solution in the
discussion
which portion of discussion helped him
to have a solution we don't know
through the discussion as he involved
active in the discussion he could able
to find out the solution so such kind of
things also has happened
in many scenarios
right so only thing you need to
participate in such community forums
actually
so then master the pmbok guide
so here it says sixth edition actually
the latest version is seventh edition
so for you
you will have a material learning
operations material which is from pmi
which will be shared with you
as a register for pmp training
that is one set of material you will
have other one is lms i said
once you go through that
please go through pmbok to understand
further more details in depth
understanding so this will help in
building foundation for preparation
uh it may be helping you in
understanding the topic better and can
give the different perspective
so remember this as i repeatedly read
something as i repeatedly do something
new uh gates will open actually
you will broaden the perspective of that
particular topic
for example as i
practice cycling every day i will learn
the tips and tricks on terms of many
different
circles which i can do using the bicycle
same way if i read a story again and
again you can practice this and
when i read a story i get some
visibility they do read a story it will
give
some more visibility day three read the
same story it will give some more
visibility
so that small story keeps giving you
more and more perspective associated
with it
same way
repetition is prerequisite for mastery
that is very very important so that is
the reason as you practice the material
in learning operations and as you
practice in lms
please go through pmbok guide also and
how will i get the pmbok guide should i
purchase somewhere no
as you become the member of pmi you can
download the pmbok guide it is very of
cost to you as
a member of the pmi
so then
35 hours of project management training
you should use this
means actively participate during the
training
simple learns provide
flexi pause also where people will come
and attend the training regularly
for the duration of subscription what
they will have and you can
practice it
and be active with the
during the session with the trainer so
lot of questions lot of queries are
answered there people participate
actively
then
that that's something what you will miss
during the training is if you don't
interact you will be lost because your
concentration level will go down
uh whether it is a regular classroom or
online so simple learn runs online
virtual classroom sessions
for retail batches whereas corporates it
has an option to
option given to the people to have a
classroom session so after pandemic most
of them has become out of classroom only
and with the modern environment i think
you also used
to modern environment where you are
working remotely as well so you know the
nitty-gritties of it so active
participation always helps
so you should connect with the topic
and you should
grab things from the source who is the
source here the trainer is the source
you should pull the information from the
trainer as much as possible which is
very very important
so as as a trainer when i go and train
the people what happens i would be
preparing for some xyz topics
as i speak about xyz topics i deep dive
into it without my knowledge who will
pull me to that level participantly as
they keep asking the questions as they
tell their own
challenges what they face
and their examples of success
this contributes to the session
and that will help trainer also to bring
more clarity in terms of practices so
part actively participate that is very
important right so
seventh tip
is to
be calm and focused
now
why should i be calm so to concentrate
there should there should not be any
disturbance so since it is online
proctor examination i will show you some
do's and don'ts of that also
and where to find what information also
i will show you
so please go through lot of mock test
what is there in
lms
then build that confidence in you and
then go for
the examination so just give me one
moment i will go through pmi's website
now
and then
there i will be
showing you
many details which would help you in
terms of putting things into practice so
website is pmi.org
so i hope part is visible to all of you
so i'll go to certifications
so these are the certifications many
certifications were pmi offers
so pmp that's what our interest is
project management professional
now i told you about membership i'll
tell you that let me open this
membership page also
so that
going through that will become easier
right
so now
[Music]
as i go down you can see here
pmp perspective look at this grouped
into three domains
people dominate
process domain business environment
domain and
approaches will be predictive adaptive
and hybrid agile is called as adaptive
so
detail of that will this will understand
as you go through the training for the
moment our understanding is three
domains and three approaches for project
management
which any project would have right
so now we will come across these two
handbooks which will have examination
content outline
and the certification handbook
these are the two things
i have downloaded that holiday i'll show
you now prerequisite for examination if
someone holds four year degree
36 months of reading projects is
essential so 36 months means three years
now should there be experience of
project management continuously three
years no in the past eight years this 36
months can be distributed the way it is
number of projects no limit
and should you be a project manager no
again
at any capacity in the projects you may
uh having some leading experience
leading projects area i am an sme in
some technology area
i led that portion of the project for
so-and-so project that is also okay so
leading and managing some portion of
project is very important for for to
have this qualification
second thing is 35 hours of project
management education
where
you will get as you go through the pmp
stream so capm certificate is a
certified associate in project
management
which is offered by pmi itself which
does not ask for any uh
previous experience when you go for capm
certification if you have that
certification you need not go for
training
you can only have this experience and
directly you can take up if you are four
year degree holder
if you are not a degree holder you have
a school diploma high school diploma or
associate degree
then leading project experience would
become 60 months
so from 36 months and this remains 35
hours of project management education
would remain
so this you should know
and then
let me go down now examination fee if
you observe since i am sitting in india
it is showing in inr
but whichever the part of the globe you
belong to accordingly you can check
so this is the difference you can see
the membership fee i will show you so
you can note down these numbers member
versus non-member you can note down the
numbers
23 versus 42 whereas if you are what is
that membership fee 9963 plus 772 let me
assume this as 10k
right
for the discussion purpose so 23 plus 10
is 33 so let me assume with this 459 and
there 700 something is around
35 k is the fee i'm just giving an
assumption
with the member with the membership
which is still lesser than the
non-member around 7k seven and a half
key kind of thing
so that is first advantage as you become
the member
second many more advantages you will
have as you become members
will automatically be part of pmi
community
so these two will come
by default as a member as a register
these two will be there
but as a member you can download pmbok
you will have a libraries to access lot
of tools and templates you can gain pdus
for your renewal of certification you
can participate in many
initiatives of pmi
right that is the membership part of it
so
this is very important when you take up
examination please become a member
explore things in pmi's website
and you can able to learn many things
stores and you will actually
tend to renew this membership again and
again
then as i go through this
requirements if i click on this
so on the pmp certification if i click
on this
so what is that requirement we're
speaking about
so a lot of details so need the
certification to get the next stage in
my career so a lot of people are put
across what exactly it helps
in terms of getting into pmp go through
them it is very inspiring thing what you
should know
and
how to apply
[Music]
so if i go to how to apply
so you will have a four-year degree as i
mentioned 36 months you need to record
this in the pmp application
then 36 months of experience 35 hours of
project management training you will
fill all the details
as you go through application once you
complete the training
right so the guidelines is here
you can follow this and then you can do
it
so
application checklist
so if i go through the application
checklist
uh a lot of details you might require
you get it what are the
one i should have as part of this let me
do this
it's very small
right so you have to keep information in
mind complete your application
what is that
the details of your experience project
professional project work experience
right
um you cannot exp put this
like your academic research or personal
wedding or newsletters or improvement
projects so it so happened one of the
student of mine who actually did a
project management for five to sixty
years six years very good
projects actually if you look at but the
place where he has done was a
organization which is a startup
but that startup organization has never
registered themselves
because of that the entire five years of
experience was like pmi never recognized
it
so it should not happen like that so you
should have the experience in the
organization
where
that that is recognized well that is
very important
so all the projects include are listed
individually
not listed multiple projects as one
entry you should not do that separately
you need to fill the details of each
project
then i have included the two title of
projects or basic descriptor project
purpose not my role on the project the
title field
like crm implementation project this
should be okay actually because sort of
confidential information you will have
you may
depict something which is related to
that project but take the help of your
managers
never ignore them managers who are
supervisors who are supposed to
confirm your experience when you are
filling these applications
so then each of my project description
are high level summaries of the project
in total that's what expected what is
outcome of the project what is the
objective of the project
and then what is your role in the
project what was the result of the
project likewise in brief summary i
think you know 250 to 500 words you may
require to
mention and start date end date
approximately
[Music]
project entries do not include routine
operation administrative task you should
not do that
so someone is in operation and say i
have a project management experience
wrong you should not do that
i have accurately indicated number of
team members who participate in this
project and budget for the project so
you should do that exact numbers they
will not ask
there will be drop down while you fill
the application in that like 10 to 25
25 to 50 likewise you'll have the slabs
kind of thing you can select that
if i am selected for pmi audit process i
am able to obtain proper verification
project experience listed in my
application so your application may get
selected for audit
as you fill the application submit that
may get selected for audit you need to
fulfill that audit requirements
by producing the proofs
which are uh
genuine details
uh that all the details you have
submitted is right or not
okay let me go back in this online
proctor i will show you afterwards sorry
let me go back here
to pmp's page
pmp exam prep
right
so
so you should undergo a training from
atp
right
so i explained that already so
far is the first thing because that is
one of the prerequisite authorized
training partner instructor like
training so simple one is one such
recognized training organization
then uh pmi authorized on demand paper
exam prep is also something which you
can do self study like you can register
for self study simply only and you can
do that
and then take the practice examination
in the lms and then prepare for the
examination
so
how does an examination questions look
like prototype
now if you look at it match the
following questions though
so you have this match each process in
the project stakeholder management with
this associated process group
processes and process group you can just
map it that is that is one type of
questions you can have
next is like you have picture graph
hotspot questions we call it is
right question is click the area where
cost will increase the most
right so this is one quick question
other one is risk register is given
based on the current risk register in
the scenario described
which entry should the project manager
edit
so you should understand what content
should get into this register and what
is relevant what is not relevant so you
will have that narratives given based on
which you can
select the right answer
so that is the prototype questions
the application part i ran you through
then
[Music]
let me go up
certification resources
on this
let me come here
so current exam
[Music]
so current exam if i go through
i said three domains non-examination
would look like this
180 questions
earlier it was 200
means before
giant 2021 it was 200 questions so that
you leave it don't worry
180 questions 230 minutes
which i told you already
so you will have 10 minutes break
for your computer-based test
since it is online proctored you might
require to have a break and also what it
takes uh in terms of when you go for
online procter examination i will show
you that also
so we'll see that so content outline
will see and i'll show you one more
thing before we move forward
that is a
pmp exam reference list
right
so
i said
hi practice guide from pmi is one
reference
pmbok guide is other reference this is
the two main references
along with that you have all of these
references like project management a
systems approach to planning scheduling
and controlling by
harold kersener similarly you have lot
of reference like this so
i think as a practicing project manager
you should go through these books
without fail
then this is very important note
the exam is based on the pmp
certification examination content
outline not pmbok or other reference
books
a guide to the pmbok seventh edition
will now be referenced to inform
development of exam items however
before any validated exam item it is
added to exam there will be very
recorded and thorough review and field
test cycle this process takes multiple
months
now when this is taking so much of
effort and you have a lot of effort
being put by pmi itself to do this just
imagine what should be your preparation
the effort for your preparation very
very essential
right
now examination day essential
what you should have
so if you work smarter on the schedules
as i mentioned earlier
so visit the test center in advance so
you can know precisely how to get there
if you are going for an examination
center
so if it is online i think a lot of
preparations you will have that i will
show you the video itself will show you
so that you can understand
so as you go in the allotted time slot
you should ensure you'll have id proofs
carried along with you
right and the stuff you don't need to
have in the examination center of the
calculator
right you need not have smartphone or
mobile phones very important let me come
back to this pmp page
so please go through this examination
update and everything etc
so online proctored examination
so here uh online proctored examination
you can take it sitting stick sitting it
uh sitting in your home itself you can
schedule 24 hours
but it has its own
pointers which you should know
so you should have a computer with a
webcam
and then it is compute center based
i mean
you should have that
online examination which is not
center-based
but if you are going for online
examination in a center
then you will physically although they
will not carry anything that is very
important
if you are taking at home scheduling you
should have the computer with webcam
reliable internet connection a quiet
space where no disturbance etc
so i think i'll play this video for you
so which would be an interesting video
uh what are the do's and don'ts for the
examination
so let me play that for you
and you can watch it each month
thousands of pmi candidates just like
you take an online proctored exam the
vast majority complete the exam without
issue here's everything you need to know
to be successful as well
although testing from home may seem
unfamiliar it comes with its benefits
the comfort of being in your own space
the convenience of not commuting to a
test center and the familiarity of using
your own computer
before you test you'll need to run a
system test it'd be best to do this at
the same time you schedule your exam on
exam day your first task is checking in
you can start this process up to 30
minutes before your exam time it should
take about 15 minutes to finish
all communication with the proctor is in
english or japanese based on what you
selected at registration
you'll need to show pictures of your id
a driver's license or passport are among
the acceptable types your id must be
valid not expired and match the name you
registered with
the proctor will also need to see your
work area before the exam so be ready to
take some snapshots of it if it doesn't
pass the scan you won't be able to take
the test
clear any clutter off your desktop and
make sure you're not in arm's reach of
books notepads calculators sticky notes
papers pins pencils and other writing
utensils
anything on the wall with writing on it
will be inspected if you have an extra
monitor it's gotta be off and unplugged
once you upload your photos it'll take
some time to review so relax and wait
for the green light
if there's an issue the proctor may try
to chat and on occasion they may even
call yourself if so don't leave them
hanging most people are up and running
within 15 minutes of their scheduled
time if not a pop-up message will direct
you to the onview help page where you
can reach us via chat to get the problem
fixed
there are some rules for online testing
we promise these are super easy
guidelines but ignoring them could mean
your exam is revoked first you need to
be in a private area and no one nearby
because you cannot receive assistance
from others
also you're the only person allowed to
see the computer screen with the exam
questions so if someone strolls in
during your exam it could be terminated
tell everyone to keep out
if you have something to drink it must
be in a clear container food tobacco and
chewing gum are off limits while testing
remove your watch or smart watch and
leave it out of sight during the exam
using certain items could mean your exam
is terminated things like phones
headsets earbuds books notes pins
scratch paper whiteboards and more to be
safe review the written rules carefully
but good news you will be able to use a
built-in digital whiteboard for scratch
worker notes whatever you do there
remains until you wipe it during the
exam your computer will be locked down a
dramatic way of saying other apps and
software can't be running or the exam
will shut down for example virus
scanning software could be a problem so
make sure it's off
lastly for security reasons please don't
read the questions out loud
remember the proctor is there to help
everything go smoothly if you need to
reach them simply click the chat keep in
mind the proctor cannot answer questions
related to the exam content
another responsibility of the proctor is
to uphold the integrity of the
certification so you receive the credit
you deserve for your experience
commitment and hard work
you can do your part by not looking off
screen too much not covering your mouth
or face and not leaning outside the
webcam
we understand the inconvenience and
appreciate the cooperation thanks
taking a break during acp and capm exams
is not an option
leaving your desk will invalidate your
exam so you know take it easy on the
liquids you drink beforehand
however if you're taking a pmp or pba
exam one or two 10-minute breaks are
built in depending on which test you're
taking just follow the prompts that
appear after you've completed certain
sections and reviewed them when a
10-minute break is up you cannot go back
to the earlier questions if you're a
little late getting back to your seat no
problem but the extra time will be
deducted from the total time available
you will not be permitted to take any
breaks that are not built into the exam
randomly leaving your desk is a no-no
and will cause your exam to be
terminated
sometimes internet connections are
unstable in the crazy event that your
computer completely crashes or freezes
your exam will need to be rescheduled
just contact us via phone or chat and
we'll help you reschedule at no cost
we realize taking an online exam can be
stressful even scary pmi and pearson vue
are here to help you get past those
hurdles and succeed you can do this we
wish you the best as you pursue your
goals
[Music]
[Applause]
yes i think these are the do's and
don'ts for examination and in addition
to that we have a lot of faqs which you
can go through and at last i would show
you that handbook which i was mentioning
for examination content outline
right so
we have
three domain areas that is people
process and business environment domain
areas here we have
set of questions like 42 percent of
questions come from people to mine and
50 from process to mind
then eight percent from the business
environment domain
so each of these domain areas what is
the domain area means so these are the
high level knowledge areas
uh that essential to practice the
project management those are the three
domains what we have
and each domains will have a set of
tasks
so underlying responsibility project
manager within which
each of the domain areas so each task
will have set of enablers illustrating
the examples of the work associated with
the task
so for example for the people domain if
you take
manage conflict is the task one of the
tasks as an example you are taking that
will have an enabler like interpret the
source and stage of the conflict
analyze the context for conflict
evaluate recommend reconcile the
appropriate conflict resolutions so
same same people domain would have
around
14 tasks you can see the domain one
people you have a list of tasks like
manage conflict lead a team supporting
performance likewise you have around
14 tasks in people doing
so similarly in the process domain you
come across around 17 tasks with set of
enablers
and if i speak about business
environment to mine you will have four
tasks
now each of this uh tasks in the people
domain process domain and business
environment domain are grouped into five
lessons
right so two domains dedicated for
people domain two lessons dedicated for
process domain and one lesson dedicated
for business environment domain and your
questions will be revolving around this
three domains
uh and also the scenario will be given
uh and whatever you learned in these
three domains your application of that
in a real time that visibility you
should have while you put that into
practice
so that's about the three domains which
you should know uh about
as you go through the pmp examination
and
for today i think that's it what i have
to share with you about the examination
so that you can able to
go through it
before
you actually practice the project
management
so any questions welcome so that i can
able to
clarify that before we conclude the
session
[Music]
all right thank you so much i hope you
had a wonderful time during this session
uh please visit
www.simplyland.com for more information
on the various different
trainings offered by simpler and also i
think you will have an access to
community forum there please post your
questions relating to this and in the
youtube also you can just put across
your queries
we will come back to you answering those
all the best have a